como si yo llegara a estos equipos hayan
estado
gracias a dios tuve tuve varios entre
entrenadores que bueno aquí
pusieron por el buen camino y padres
también que me soportaron bastante y
pude hacer las salas de quebec a los 16
años que es ese es un grupo que hacen
para de los mejores 16 años de quebec
500 se van a jugar un torneo donde
y perfuman bien pues se hacen ver por
los entrenadores de tinker entonces
gracias a dios pude jugar para el equipo
nacional
en 2012 se trastearon los filis de
filadelfia pero decidí ir a la escuela
entonces
haciendo las alas de quebec y el equipo
nacional de canadá pues varias escuelas
y equipos pues pueden ver y
la capacidad ni méxico ni college que es
una escuela de dos años
y de esa escuela transferiría y
reversión y méxico
puede terminar mi bachillerato y su
licenciatura y el bachillerato en
algunos países de américa latina es como
la secundaria como el preuniversitario
mientras que la licenciatura ya es la
universidad bueno si puede terminar eso
y fui a jugar mi último año de
elegibilidad
x
entonces usted diría que el camino como
describiría entonces el camino para los
jóvenes que quieren hacer un deporte de
forma profesional digamos que es lo que
hace falta para lograr lo que usted ha
logrado porque ha logrado muchas cosas
bueno siempre decimos del deporte que no
hay que trabajar
hay que fajarse a todos los días sí
trabajar más que los demás o sea correr
esa mía
esa milla de masa de más y de ahí pues
estar en el lugar
perfecto en él
puedes decir quiero que esa persona
lo más importante es trabajar si hay una
cuestión de suerte pero más bien es el
trabajo el trabajo porque no cualquiera
se levantó una mañana y lolo
hay que trabajar
puede mantenerse al día y
cuidando su cuerpo comiendo bien y que
es importante hay mucha gente que no lo
ve así que yo puedo comer lo que sea y
me va a ir bien pero la comida y dormir
sobre todo gente estaba mencionando que
los jóvenes nos dormimos bastante pero
es importante entonces hay que hacer las
cosas bien
fue que dios
está en sus manos
yo creo que una de las cosas que deben
ser más duras para los jóvenes que
durante la adolescencia están implicados
en un deporte profesional es la cuestión
de no hacer tanto la fiesta y no ese
tanto de fiesta con los amigos ya que
ser disciplinado disciplinado y sobre
todo cuando
a las universidades o sea la fiesta
están ahí no se acostó
lo que puede impedir lograr la meta está
ahí
ay qué otra vez lo digo disciplinado no
que no pueda tener un tiempo para
relajar y pasar un buen tiempo pero
también hay que ser inteligente y
saber que al otro lado de la meta está
el suceso si quieren llegar a
profesional si quieren llegar donde
quieren llegar hay que ser bien
disciplinado y usted me estaba contando
antes de entrar al estudio que terminó
su maestría en relaciones
internacionales son sin relaciones
internacionales se llama así exactamente
relación internacional si me enfoqué en
seguridad nacional
gracias a dios ya ya terminé eso y ojalá
pueda trabajar en el estudio en el que
estudió no seguro que psicosis y hace
como hizo con el béisbol eso trato de
hacer o sea es lo que me gusta mucho del
deporte qué
el deporte nos enseña a ser disciplinado
a trabajar fuerte a hacer
en caras en lo que uno quiere
creo que es así también es lo mismo
entonces agradezco mucho lo que ha
pasado por el béisbol y lo que me ha
enseñado y nos la pueda
por eso de mi vida usar esa experiencia